foreign  [Music]  it's me  Margaret  I'm here to speak to you today about  your changing bodies the blood is  released through the vagina  ceased to this one thing for me  [Music]  let me just be normal and regular like  everybody else just please please please  please please please please please  please  I've decided I want you to join my  secret Club  if you want to be in the club then you  have to wear a bra  oh  do you think you need one  are you okay you can tell me the truth  [Music]  we have the campus  [Music]  and how are you I read that when you  don't have any loved ones around your  life expectancy drops drastically but  you know I've had a good run  [Music]  it's tiring I'm trying so hard all the  time doesn't it  I don't know if I want to do this it's  just that we're ready please God let it  be a lady  foreign  do you think any of us will look like  that when we're 19.  we must we must we must increase  [Music]